Ritchie turns was awarded the chemistry
price in 1991 alone and so I did not
count on getting a Nobel Prize because
if I was left out at that point
I had no reason to assume that I would
get the price at all and certainly not
the chemistry price now and and after
1991 when hands got so noble I got shot
a price and I got the Kyoto Prize and
there was no one who had Kyoto Prize and
the Nobel Prize you see so I have no
reason to believe you get so the only
attention that I came because of some
rumors that I come to me was as a
medicine price well there were the
rumors that I might be considered for
the medicine price and so I nobody paid
any attention to the announcement of the
chemistry price for example our
publicity Department was empty they were
on vacation the president of the school
was talking in the forest and I was
teaching and my assistant had strict
orders not to interrupt me when I'm
teaching so the call from Stockholm came
to her she said she told him she
couldn't bother me then they concluded
say at the wrong address called the
Nasser who do it in Surrey who happens
to be driver of an ambulance who worked
all night and was they woke him up from
his well-deserved sleep and they did it
three times before they they didn't
understand what was going on called the
poor guy three times and then they
understood they were on the wrong track
went back to call my secretary again and
I think it was five minutes before say
would go to the dress nothing hey this
is 10:45 or 11:45 so then they said that
they told the poor Isabel that if she
didn't get me she would be in trouble
and she still she didn't know what was
going on
aunt Angie actually came to call me out
of selection and then I recognized the
voice of the Secretary of the Academy
and so I that was it
and so I went back to the class and told
some I regret I have to stop teaching
because I got the Nobel Prize I know
that I said this because the students
and made a t-shirt please with this mrs.
comment on it and then he took about
three more minutes to have suppressing
houseand and of course no one who could
help me because the publicity Department
was empty and so that that's how it
happened